a shout out to him um so yeah on his
game mess Morning Show he indicated that
uh that the Coalition had uh basically
transferred all of their team to fully
work on the next gears game so gear six
weeks right and but that's what's
interesting about that is that a they
had been somewhat hit a little bit hit
by the layoffs at Microsoft right we
don't I don't think he actually
mentioned the actual number that they
got sort of depleted by but they were
hit by that
and in some way shape or form that kind
of could have led to the cancellation of
two smaller projects that they had been
working on if you remember after gears
five they said they were going to take
their time to sort of get their bearings
with Unreal Engine 5 before they jumped
in full-fledged into gear six not that
they weren't working on it but it wasn't
going to be the next thing the
Assumption was it was going to be a
smaller game in Unreal Engine 5 so they
could sort of get their feet wet
um apparently they were